the uk government has approved a covet
19 vaccine to be rolled out from next
week
it's accepted a recommendation to
approve the pfizer and bioentech vaccine
a committee is now working on final
advice for which people should receive
it first
that's expected to include care home
residents and health workers
the uk health secretary says that around
50 hospitals are set up
and waiting to accept the vaccine live
now to london
al jazeera steve barker is there talk us
through this
announcement when will people be able to
get this vaccine
well adrian firstly this is probably the
most hopeful announcement since the
start of the pandemic at least of course
since the
announcement that several vaccines were
being worked on by different
pharmaceuticals companies and
researchers in different places
around the world but it was of course
the pfizer bioentech
vaccine made by that team of german
scientists in partnership with the u.s
pharmaceuticals giant that came back
with
initial results from key trials to
suggest that they had
a significant effectiveness when it came
to their vaccine of more than
90 percent and now the uk
becomes the first industrialized nation
to give the green light to this vaccine
allowing it to essentially start to be
rolled out as early as next week from
monday morning said britain's health
secretary
matt hancock this morning the mhra which
is the medicines and regulatory or
authority is an
independent organization it has
basically sped up all of the checks and
balances that it needs to
go through to make sure that this
vaccine is safe
for use and now it's all down to
exactly how fast the manufacturer can
make the vaccine
to determine exactly how how many people
it can reach
but we do believe that for monday
morning
800 000 doses will be in the uk
there need to be some checks on that
vaccine before it actually leaves
belgium where the factory is actually
based
before it arrives here people will need
two doses of that
vaccine injected into the arm 21 days
apart so 800
000 doses means that 400 000 people
will receive that vaccine and of course
also a key thing to remember it's what's
known as a a key
chain vaccine so it needs to be kept at
incredibly low temperatures
minus 80 degrees centigrade
and that has to be the case throughout
the whole of
the the movement of the vaccine from one
country to another or the place of
manufacturer to the place in which it's
actually being deployed so the best
place
base poised places to receive the
vaccine are of course going to be
hospitals
but we will find out later on exactly
the order of who will get the vaccine
first
yeah who's who's in charge of deciding
who who gets it first and i mean
you gave me some huge numbers there this
is going to be a
a massive logistical operation getting
this
vaccine out to those who need it
yeah that's absolutely absolutely right
and and determining the order of who
gets the vaccine is a key one we will
find out a little bit later on when a
another key organization that advises
the government comes back with its
findings on how exactly the vaccine
should be distributed according to matt
hancock the british health secretary who
has been speaking over the course of the
morning
the british government even prior to the
uh regulator giving it the green line
green light had said that they were
ready to receive 10
million doses before the end of the year
they do believe that the majority of
people will be vaccinated at the start
of next year
but when it comes to deciding who gets
it first well the indication is that
elderly in care homes and their carers
will be at the top of the list
national health service workers will
then get it and then it will
progressively go down the ages so a huge
logistical operation underway majority
of people getting it next year
those most vulnerable very soon though
al jazeera's need barca reporting live
from london many thanks